hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome
to let's play slender
hospice
now the new hospice map was released
very recently and that sounded like a
female voice
so maybe it's the return of
the female character complete the poem
press space to place a glow stick
really now a glow stick
that's a different mechanic from what i
read on the website where i downloaded
it which you can find in the description
below if you're looking for
where to find this this map is
supposedly harder
tighter more confined and
has randomly generated
map placement
or page placement
all right very quiet in the beginning
whoa
really now ah there's a page here we go
first page slow painful death well isn't
that what the
two of sixteen lines discovered but
either way
i gotta see this
you mad bro nope.jpg
penis pewdiepie was here ah there's
another page
racist all right
coming for you that was only one line
whatever it's all the same right
okay anyway
so i don't know if the map is supposed
to be smaller or
if just it's supposed to be tighter
definitely feels more
cramped
okay is that page oh no that's not a
page that's a troll page
looks like a page
he's down there
ain't gonna get me slendy they're gonna
get me mr
man i hope there wasn't a page down
there
because i'm not going back a page no
that's another fakie fakie page
all right i'm sure this level designer
designed things so that kind of throws
you off you think you see something like
in the last map
in sanatorium he had things on the walls
that kind of looked like slenderman
okay i'm getting back to where i started
i think this is where i started
all right i'll check this area and then
i'll come up northish
see if i can't find more let's see if i
can actually get close to finishing this
game
i've never actually managed to do it so
it'd be nice
once i get a better idea of the map
layout probably when i do better
okay no pages man how do i keep getting
myself into these situations
oh wait a minute where am i going
nothing in there okay
oh boy
no page
all right doing okay so far but then we
only only got two pages
or four of 16 lines man
this is confusing i i'm getting turned
around here what's down there
ah
oh there was probably a page in there ah
paige
it's road to snare what
oh man oh that did not feel good
he's still around this corner yep he's
still there
i'm just trying to get through so that i
can
i just wanted to check to throw the page
there but there was not oh
oh oh how's he getting there oh oh oh no
oh no oh no oh no
oh no i'm going in a big circle uh uh uh
screw you
screw you screw you where'd you go screw
you wherever you went i hope you went to
screw yourself shove one of your arms
ready to be butt
okay i already checked these rooms
there's nothing in there
oh he's getting closer oh run run run
oh run oh go faster oh you're so slow
no pages what's that what is that uh
i don't know some deal or those donators
i think i read something about it
ah paige
i think they improved the slenderman
mechanics and
no oh
oh okay i think yeah
what i was trying to say is i think they
approve the slender band mechanics i
think he's really
better at getting closer to you
oh i don't think i don't know
okay dear robin oh should i travel
through the woods
or should i we're not wishing i would
for above me lurks within the trees
no one can hear my deathly screams the
palest man the blackest suit
bigger than the tallest brute okay
okay oh man yeah he's uh i don't know if
i need to like turn around and keep my
eye
to where he was not looking at him of
course but
just to keep him from popping up
okay let's try it again let's go again
because i'm a fool to myself
let's do this
don't do that okay
yeah it's definitely a female
i know women and that sounds like a
woman lady
hospice okay
so what was this about place a glow
stick
let me just okay what does that do oh it
helps me know where i've been
ah doesn't really glow but all right
let's just go
quickly into this area
get the page ah first page right off the
bat okay
okay can't run can't hide okay i got you
i gotcha i gotcha okay i'm just gonna
go through here because this is where
i've been right
or this is where i came through last
time or no i got turned around
i don't know either way just keep moving
forward
was that paige that's a thank you page
god all right
oh this is oh this is here wow how'd i
get turn around here
i don't know sure no this is different
ah man but here's the page always look
always look back
aha say i told you guys some of you guys
were telling me that
looking back was a bad idea i knew it
was a good idea
because you got to keep your eye on him
without looking at him directly
otherwise he'll just creep up on you and
he'll get you
he'll getcha he'll just come up and
getcha ah
save me no i don't think i will i do not
think i will
i'm worried about myself here i'm very
worried about myself
okay keep my eye out just keeping an eye
out
okay another glow stick
and here oh yeah
make good progress slow painful death
yeah i get it i'm gonna die
i haven't seen him which is weird
considering i have eight pages or four
oh this is back here
come on you buddy oh no this is the dead
end
oh but there's a page coming for you i
know
okay don't be around that corner slendy
i've got my eye on you yeah that's right
oh okay we're okay
because he ain't gonna get me i don't
know if there was a page back there but
it doesn't seem like there would be
because i got too many pages
nope nope go i got my oh i in the
general direction that you was were
run faster please
lose them
oh oh oh okay went that way good thing i
placed that
there oh what's down that high i don't
think i've been down here
okay oh yeah oh no oh no
no i don't know where i am oh this isn't
where i put the gloves to
i don't know i thought i was
i think i lost him for a moment in here
no oh nothing
oh
no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
ah i've been here oh don't tell me
no how
oh i'm down here i've been here how did
i go down the same way
oh i don't know i don't know oh
i need to get like to the other side of
the building because that's where all
the pages are i'm
lately wandering around the same side oh
oh he's right there he's right there oh
oh i hate you i hate you slender man i
hate everything about you
your suit is ugly your face is ugly even
though you don't have one
your mother wouldn't even love your face
oh okay i'm getting i i think i'm near
back where
this um yeah that's the thing okay let
me go
up this way now oh oh
he's so close to getting me he's not
gonna get me
not again okay that ah yeah
this is the other wing oh god i can get
the pages i can get the page and get out
of here
i can actually win i can do this oh gosh
okay not that way this way
okay oh okay
put one here all right this way
okay all right we're good we're good
ah how what no no
no oh
how did i no no no i went in the
complete other direction
uh because i went through there
that said i didn't put that down because
i went through there
oh no no not this dumb buddy
you go [ __ ] right off
please tell me i'm in a new direction
oh i don't know i don't know i keep
getting freaking ah
paige always hunting okay that's
phenomenal
oh oh i can't run oh i'm out of run
juice i'm out of run juice
oh
oh okay
dear groban oh should i travel through
the woods
or should i not wishing i would for
above me lurks within the trees no one
can bear
hear my deathly screams the palest man
the blackest suit
bigger than the tallest brute six black
turns will grab you up
or stalk you till you just give up a top
hat bears upon his head
makes your soul fill up with dread he
takes you when you least expect
boil you up and eat your neck
okay oh
oh okay that's enough for now
oh oh man
okay all right that's enough for now
oh it's really cool
yeah it's really cool that this guy is
releasing new maps like this
that changes up the experience because
one things i didn't like about the first
letters was all the same
it looks all the same in just a big open
area so oh man
that was good i like how he improved the
slender man mechanic so he obviously
comes for you quicker and quicker it
i get it i get the mechanics better than
sanatorium which seems like kind of just
got ya but anyway that was very good so
oh boy oh man let me know in the
comments if you want more of
this one or sanatorium or the original
slender because
whoo these get me these really get me
but anyway thank you all so much for
watching and as always
i will see you in the next part
bye bye